this is a lightsaber it can cut through
just about anything and some people have
even made them in real life to see
everything they can cut through but
today we're going to find out what they
can't cut can they cut through Diamond
Wolverine's claws Thor's hammer or even
Captain America's shield let's find out
to understand what lightsabers can and
can't cut through we first need to know
how hot they are since we don't know for
certain we can assume the blades are
made of plasma which is capable of
reaching temperatures of 8 000 to 25 000
degrees Celsius that's hotter than the
surface of the Sun
[Music]
now our first Contender Mandalorian
armor or best car as we've seen in the
Mandalorian television series
Mandalorian armor and bescar is able to
withstand plasma bolts and lightsabers
for extended periods of time with a
melting point of higher than 20 000
degrees Celsius it would be pretty hard
for a lightsaber to cut through it but
perhaps with the hottest lightsaber and
the weakest best car it could cut
through it with time up next Captain
America's shield this Shield is made of
a vibranium alloy one of the strongest
substances in the Marvel Universe
unfortunately a lightsaber would be able
to cut right through it vibranium has a
melting point of 5475 degrees Celsius
and lightsabers can reach up to 25 000
degrees so although we love cap and his
shield a lightsaber would cut through it
like butter our next Contender is
Wolverine's claws made of adamantium the
hardest substance in the Marvel Universe
although it has a melting point of 1500
degrees Celsius it becomes basically
indestructible after eight minutes of
cooling due to the changes in its
molecular structure it's able to
withstand temper temperatures greater
than a hundred thousand degrees Celsius
for extended periods of time so a
lightsaber would not be able to cut
through adamantium or through Wolverine
up next is Thor's hammer mjolnir which
is made of uru a metal ore from the
first moon in existence in the Marvel
universe as we saw in Avengers Infinity
war uru is only able to be melted by the
heat from the core of a star which can
reach temperatures greater than 18
million degrees Celsius so Thor's hammer
would be able to smack a lightsaber
around like it's nothing lightsabers
aren't hot enough to cut through uru so
they'd lose this match up against
mjolnir our next content vendor is
pretty interesting Hulk's skin what
would happen if you hit the Hulk with a
lightsaber probably nothing as we know
the Infinity Stones were capable of
melting and destroying The Infinity
Gauntlet which was made of uru we know
the heat they gave off was likely much
greater than a few million degrees also
we know the Hulk was able to survive
using the Infinity Stones so a
lightsaber at a few thousand degrees
Celsius would probably do nothing to the
whole now what about real life minerals
diamonds for example well a lightsaber
would be able to cut right through your
precious diamond ring since diamonds
have a melting point of around 700
degrees Celsius well what about the
substance with the highest melting point
on Earth hafnium again unfortunately a
lightsaber would cut right through that
too since its melting point is 4215
degrees Celsius we know lightsabers
don't cut through other lightsaber
blades but what else can stop them in
the Star Wars Galaxy in Star Wars
Legends it was shown that the rare metal
frick was able to withstand lightsaber
blows and it was used in the
construction of electrostaffs
Palpatine's lightsabers Dark Trooper
armor and a holocron that was actually
able to survive the destruction of
Alderaan up next is cortosis another
rare metal that would actually short out
lightsabers on contact it was used in
crafting melee weapons and armor and was
able to withstand multiple lightsaber
blows before melting the lightsaber
wielder though would have to wait until
their shorted out lightsaber turned back
on each time before striking again a
couple more metals that could resist
lightsaber blades were geranium and song
steel mentioned only in the Star Wars
role-playing games one of the most
interesting substances to withstand
lightsaber strikes though was the height
of the Zillow Beast featured in Star
Wars the Clone Wars since the tide was
resistant to lightsabers Emperor
Palpatine secretly tried to study it in
order to make lightsaber-resistant armor
for his Clone Army but as far as we know
he failed in this endeavor the last and
maybe the most controversial item to be
able to withstand a lightsaber blade is
the Z6 riot control baton featured in
The Force awakens in this scene Finn
fights a first order Stormtrooper with
an electrified baton which many people
think shouldn't be able to hold back a
lightsaber lightsabers though are likely
just plasma held together by a strong
magnetic field in the force just outside
the field you likely wouldn't feel any
heat but once you cross into the field
you'd feel the full 25 000 degrees of
the lightsaber so it's possible that
this baton's electrical field had some
way of holding back the magnetic field
on the lightsaber rather than actually
withstanding the heat of the lightsaber
itself but I'd like to know what you
think would a lightsaber actually be
able to cut through Captain America's
shield or Wolverine's claws drop your
thoughts in the comment section below
also check out the video on your screen
for some more of my content don't forget
to like And subscribe and thanks for
watching Rocket Riley
[Music]
thank you